[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que vous ai pas parlé
de rumeur de téléphone et là je vais
vous parler de samsung de rumeurs sur le
prochain
flagship de samsung sortira début 2010
neuf qui sera normalement présenté au
mwc avant en tout cas quelques jours
avant le mwc peut-être même la veille à
barcelone au mois de février c'est le
samsung galaxy s 10 on a eu cette année
le s9 l'année d'avant le f8 faut savoir
que tous les deux ans samsung sort un
modèle évolution un vrai modèle avec de
vraies belles évolutions la vraie dalle
évolution représente maintenant à
l'année dernière avec le galaxy s suit
le s9 de cette année est une belle
évolution du et suit notamment la caméra
à ouverture variable mais voilà c'est
bien mais je pense que l'année prochaine
en 2010 là qu'on va avoir vraiment
quelque chose qui valait encore plus
loin apporter de la nouveauté de tout
cas on voit vraiment que les smartphones
et voulu de plus en plus samsung est
jamais succomber à la gauche jamais
jamais jamais jamais beaucoup d'autres
constructeurs s'y sont mis et l'année
prochaine il devrait y avoir du
changement du côté de chez samsung
toujours pas dans koch a priori mais un
design qui devrait être revu
repenser en tout cas améliorer on devra
voir d'écran que pris 93 4% de la face
avant avec quasiment pas de bord en eau
quasiment pas de bord en bas sur les
côtés un écran incurvé et un appareil
photo vraiment intégré à l'écran alors
soit il serait positionné sous l'écran
soit on aura un léger petit robe
découpée au milieu de l'écran pour faire
apparaître l'appareil photo sans corde
pour l'interrogation c'est pas
exactement vers quelle option va diriger
samsung voilà un peu pour l'idée
générale pour concept et design général
maintenant il faut savoir qu'on devrait
avoir trois nouveaux smartphones en 2010
offre un petit peu comme ce qu'a fait
apple avec son iphone 10 16 17 max et le
10 r on devait donc avoir un modèle plus
low cost ça serait un ace disque lite on
devrait avoir un modèle un peu plus
standards comme le snof suite ça serait
le s10 l'évolution en tout cas ça me
paraissait normal et le modèle un peu
plus grand plus grand écran comme le s9
plus on aurait le s10 plus trois
nouveaux modèles qui devraient être
présentées début
des oeuvres et samsung irait encore plus
loin parce qu'elle pourrait intégrer
pour le marché américain
sur le modèle plus une puce 5g pour
avoir effectivement la 5g
il y aurait quelques variations d'un
point de vue design entre les trois
modèles le modèle standard aurait des
côtes et légèrement incurvé comme ce
qu'on peut retrouver déjà en terme de
design sur le s9 descoings légèrement
arrondi tandis que le modèle d'entrée de
gamme modèle light ne devraient pas
avoir ce côté arrondi avoir un écran
peut plus standard et le mode être plus
forcément plus grands bords arrondis
full option ça va de soi on aura bien
évidemment un écran super amoled je vous
le dis version standard ça serait un 5,8
pouces connaît la qualité des écrans de
samsung on s'inquiète pas dans tous les
cas on aura vraiment des écrans au top
[Musique]
un standard avec cette fameuse lentilles
ouverture variable f1 points 5 f 2.4
pour s'adapter en fonction des
conditions de luminosité on aurait un
tel objectif x 2 qui vous aiderait promo
de portraits pis pour le zoom optique
on aurait également un très grand angle
et puis d'un point de vue logiciel ouvre
aussi une vraie révolution avec un
meilleur hdr de nouveaux capteurs
toujours plus performants pour des
photos de meilleure qualité en faible
luminosité
et tout ça a aidé par un socle gravé en
7 nanomètres qui mettrait à profit toute
l'énergie toute la puissance que vous
avez au moment opportun ce qui fait un
smartphone avec beaucoup plus
d'autonomie des performances optimisées
meilleures capacités de calcul au niveau
des photos dans des photos complètement
améliorées dont du hdr améliorée des
rangers mais l'horreur fabuleuse été
beaucoup mieux enfin toute une machine
complètement améliorée et sur le modèle
plus on aurait une batterie de 4000
milliampères heures comme on assure le
samsung galaxy note 9 en termes de
mémoire vive on pourrait aller jusqu'à
12 giga octet de ram pour le modèle le
plus haut de gamme incluant de la 5g qui
ne serait pas dispo sans marché français
mais en tout cas sur le marché américain
est ce que vraiment intéressant c'est la
caméra donc parce qu'on aura justement
une petite caméra toutes rondes intégrer
directement à l'écran alors mais la
question c'est est-ce que cette caméra
va être intégré complètement derrière
l'écran et fera quand même des photos
d'excellente qualité ou alors est ce
qu'on aura en tout petits dés coups au
niveau de l'écran pour laisser passer
cette caméra ça serait une interactive
assez intéressante en tout cas ce qu'on
voit vraiment c'est que on a eu
l'encoche l'encoche existe encore elle
disparaît un peu ça dépend des besoins
qu'on a sont une caméra avec un capteur
3d si on a juste un appareil photo on a
aujourd'hui les petites encoches en
forme de goutte comme honda sur le wan
pu assister comme on assure le may 20 de
huawei d'auckland coche de vrai
disparaître en tout cas commencé à
disparaître en 2019 pour avoir carrément
plus du tout dans coche lors pourquoi
pas une toute petite découper on le voit
d'ailleurs avec le haut pour finding
cette année on l'a vu également avec le
mime x3 qui va arriver très très très
prochainement de xiaomi d'avoir un
appareil photo de celle fille qu'on peut
sortir fermé pour avoir un seul même et
grand écran pour déverrouiller votre
smartphone vous auriez le capteur
d'empreintes digitales directement
intégré à l'écran quand on peut trouver
sur le match d'impro comment tu trouves
et sur le one + 6 t et qui marche plutôt
pas mal par contre assez mauvaise
nouvelle le port jack pourrait
disparaître alors ça me saoule a
toujours continué à garder son temps
jack a fait de la résistance
la banque ou sans galaxy s 10 la prise
jack pourrait disparaître pour aller
vraiment vers un des casques connecter
sans fil ça ça pourrait être douloureux
autre point qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est d'avoir un haut
parleur qui complètement caché ici au
niveau de l'écran comme vous l'avez sur
le médecin ou alors sur le web pucistes
et haut-parleurs qui est très léger très
profilé ce qui fait que ça vous permet
de dégager complètement l'écran du coup
une raison utile au niveau de l'écran et
qui viendrait pas rogner donc ce qui
nous permettrait effectivement d'avoir
ce grand écran qui occuperait 93 4% la
face avant et ça pour le coup ça serait
plutôt cool et cotées au s il tournerait
sur android 9 pas y paraît plutôt
logique
en tout cas ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant à travers toutes ces rumeurs
c'est d'être capable un petit peu de
voir étant dans ce devoir là où vont
aller les grands constructeurs samsung
c'est pas un petit constructeur c'est
pas une petite marque c'est vraiment un
des leaders son marché qui a fait des
choix stratégiques notamment de ne pas
avoir dans le coche d'eau qui sont la
problématique comme tous les fabricants
d'avoir des plus grands écrans toujours
pour du multimédia dans des smartphones
qui tiennent toujours dans la main un
format toujours un peu réduit entre
guillemets on voit qu'ils procèdent
ligne un petit peu sur le choix
stratégique qu'a fait apple avec ses
trois smartphones pour l'année prochaine
qui dit smartphone qui tient dans la
main qui dit grand écran 10
problématique un petit peu au niveau des
capteurs au niveau de l'appareil photo
de lady intégré l'appareil photo sous
l'écran ça pour être brûlés
belle technologie voir un petit peu de
quelle manière tout ça va être mis en
place début 2010 neuf donc bien
évidemment on ira le voir qui sera
présentée on en parlera dans l'épisode
tout ça vous inquiétez pas donc je vous
invite à faire comme d'hab vous abonner
à rester connectés parce que de toute
façon début 2019
on a deux grands rendez-vous principaux
et majeur le tout premier ça avec le cms
début janvier je vais m'envoler
direction las vegas après un petit oeil
par new york quelques jours avant pour
vraiment aller voir un peu les
nouveautés prendre le pouls de la tech
internationale et puis le deuxième grand
rendez-vous cet hommage février ont valu
au mwc à barcelone devrait être présenté
sur tout cas ils le font comme l'année
dernière juste la veille le nouveau s10
de samsung donc on dit sera on verra on
prendre en main on le découvrira et on
fera tous les tests ne vous inquiétez
pas dont vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui
vous abonner dites-moi ce que ce que
vous pensez tout ça vous comment est-ce
que voudriez qu'ils soient ce galaxy s
10 quelles sont vos attentes
est ce que vous voudriez vraiment un
smartphone avec un écran toujours tout
vent est ce que l'idée cet appareil
photo intégré sous l'écran à cette
petite découpe au niveau de l'écran pour
vous un sens est-ce que vous pensez que
samsung va dans le bon sens est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est bien que samsung
est parfait dans coche et qu'est ce que
vous pensez
la potentielle disparition de cette
prise jack voila voila je suis un vieux
dino je suis toujours un petit peu
râleur là dessus mais qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous est ce que pour nous
c'est un problème
oui ou non et qu'est ce que vous pensez
de l'idée d'avoir trois modèles comme
l'a fait apple un modèle standard
un modèle plus comme on a toujours eu
depuis quelques années en tout cas et
puis un modèle plus low cost est ce que
ce modèle low cost va venir un petit peu
rogné sur la gamme assez la gamme s
reste quand même le haut de gamme est ce
qu'un modèle low cost sur la gamme s1
chance chez samsung
voilà vous marquez tout ça en
commentaires et vous me dites ce que
vous en pensez
comme d'habitude je vous invite à me
dire tout ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire on reste connectés d'ici là
soyez sages portez vous bien et vous
donne rendez vous extrêmement rapidement
pour continuer bien évidemment à parler
de textes shout
[Musique]
où